so as Jared said my name is Michele Gill
I'm a senior data scientist at
benevolent AI so I sort of trained
myself up in in data science and machine
learning after after I became a
scientist so that's the side of the coin
that one there
so put your chemistry hats on because
we're going to talk about artificial
intelligence and chemistry today so a
little bit about benevolent AI before I
begin we are 200 life scientists a AI
scientists bioinformaticians chem
informaticians and we all work side by
side towards the purpose of rapidly
accelerating drug discovery our
technique our technology pipeline is
validated in-house by our own
experimental results we have drug
discoverers chemists as well and we're
the only AI company with capabilities
from the early stage through the late
stage of the drug development process so
before we begin a little bit of a
biochemistry nomenclature so a target so
this may look like the Packman that
Jared mentioned this morning if you were
here but we're gonna do a dual purpose
our Packman so this is a target and this
is a molecule within an organism that is
associated with a disease and it's the
intended the intended destination for a
therapy often this is actually a protein
in real life it doesn't look like a
pac-man so a compound or lead is a
chemical that binds to this target and
it it will cure it or treat a disease
unfortunately usually when you first
find a compound that will bind to a
target it has other properties that are
undesirable drug discovery is a really
complicated process and so some of those
properties that we try to optimize after
we discover a lead things like we want
it to be extremely effective at low
doses we wanted to have a low amount of
side-effects
we don't want it to be toxic obviously
and so once we go through the iterative
process of optimizing those properties
we call it a drug so that's a compound
or lead who has been that has been
highly optimized through this iterative
process and so if that sounds like a
long and arduous process to you you'd be
correct there are estimates that it can
take between 1.8 billion that's actually
a low estimate
get all the way from the early stages of
drug discovery through the three phases
of clinical trials and to submission and
it can also take in excess of ten years
the higher estimates are about two and a
half billion to about fifteen years so
it's an incredibly long process and so
our our goal of benevolent AI is to
accelerate this process with machine
learning and so we use a variety of data
sources we use publicly available
datasets databases we have our own
unstructured pipeline where we mined the
scientific literature remind patents
abstracts all kinds of textual data we
also have our in-house experimental data
that we feedback and we aggregate this
all together into a a graph that we use
to train our machine learning models and
so we use that throughout all stages of
the drug discovery process so from
target identification the early stages
through lead optimization which is
actually what I'm going to tell you a
little bit about today and then the
results from lead optimization feed into
our own clinical trials and that again
feeds back into our graph of knowledge
that we maintain and so a little bit
about lead optimization sort of my
favorite part of the drug discovery
process is what we're going to cover so
exploring the compound universe is
incredibly challenging the the space of
compounds is between 10 to the 20 and 10
to the 60 depending upon how you
estimate it but often we're only
interested in really small regions of
this compound space and they're very
discrete and so what we want to do and
this is the actual representation of a
compound the wake a chemist or drat
they're not really squares or triangles
is identify a compound that binds to
that target and then we're going to use
exploration to sort of it early scan
through that space by making small
changes as we hope to identify these and
improve these properties so if you those
of you are a computer scientists you
might be thinking of this as sort of a
search policy or search a search method
and it kind of is and so we can
formulate this as a problem that we can
address with machine learning and
perhaps use generative algorithms which
I'll go over in just a moment to create
novel compounds and you know these
machine learning
models no and have been trained on a
vast array of compounds and so hopefully
they can help us identify compounds that
have these better improved properties
that could convert them into drugs so so
just to really pose the question how can
we efficiently explore such a vast
universe in a property driven and in a
really efficient way so this is what the
compound design cycle looks like so a
chemist based on experimental knowledge
based on their own knowledge that
they've learned through experiments will
design a compound then the chemist has
to synthesize it usually through a
multi-step process in the lab and then
we'll test so a variety of experimental
assays that will test the properties of
the compound the safety all of these
things that we really need to improve
upon however if we're able to sort of
supplement our chemists with it with an
AI version of our chemist we can
accelerate this process by doing some of
these steps in silico so we call this
the de novo design process and it
parallels what I just described in real
life so that process in the
computational sense looks like this so
we will design a compound through search
and optimization policies and then we
will make it which is really actually
quite trivial because computers can know
how they know how to assemble molecules
we have various rules we have programs
that do this for us and then we can test
it so we use machine learning models to
predict these properties to to determine
if it will actually bind to a
computational representation of our
target and and then we can iterate much
more quickly computationally and then be
selective about what we decide to take
back into the lab and test
experimentally so this is sort of like a
generative model which for those of you
who maybe don't have experience with
this this is a in this context it's
specifically a deep learning model
that's going to generate compounds and
we're going to it's going to help us
guide what experiments we do so drug
discovery is really a multi parameter
optimization problem I've sort of
alluded to that but we have a lot of
properties that we need to think about
at once more properties honestly than a
human even
great chemists can really keep sort of
keep track of it at one time so we want
it to what's called affinity we want
this compound to really bind to our
target well so that we don't have to use
as much of it when when we dose people
so we want to minimize the amount that
of the pill you have to take for example
we want it to not be very toxic we don't
want to harm the organism otherwise you
know those are those are side-effects
and we want us to be selective those are
kind of toxicities lexa selectivity are
kind of related but we don't we only
want it to really bind to the target
that we're interested in dosing so so
this multi parameter objective we can
use this with our machine learning
models
so let's talk about how we generate the
best compounds so this is a sort of a
schema of what our how our model
training works so we use a variety of
compound data I'm from this this graph
that we generate and we feature eyes the
compounds and we'll go into more depth
about this to create what we call a
general model we then refine that
general model with reinforcement
learning and user feedback and from this
model we're able to get optimized
compounds so as a very brief aside
machine learning actually has a very
very long history in chemistry so this
is a paper and I know you can't read the
date but it's from 1991 and this is
Johann Gauss tiger who is a very famous
computational chemist and in this paper
he he sort of muses that that neural
networks might be the next big thing in
chemistry in 1991 it's very funny to
read it because it reads like a lot of
articles today so fast forward 17 years
and we've graduated from sort of the
standard feed-forward networks the gas
Tiger was using to - deep learning
models and Kemble is a particular
database but we're able to do very large
scale machine learning with the kind of
data that we have in chemistry this
today and and obviously we use far more
sophisticated models so going back to
our talking about how we generate the
best compounds so how do we represent
molecules to a machine learning model
normally if you have columns of data you
features perhaps you tried to create
some sort of I don't know
embedding how do we how do we represent
molecules well there's some tricks so so
one of the ways that we really represent
these molecules so that we can teach
these neural networks how to predict
them we borrow some some ideas from
language models so you all type on your
phone usually it gets good at predicting
what your next word might be the text so
we can borrow from this and use adapt
these language models to help feature
eyes our compounds so there's something
called smiles which I will explain to
you briefly in just a moment but that's
how we can represent these compounds so
you can see this compound on the right
and it can be represented with two CS
and an equal sign so there's a numerical
trick for representing these as text and
then we can adapt what what language
models have taught us in deep learning
and so effectively what these models are
really doing is simply predicting then
what the next character is based on the
previous ones and so this I told you
this is called smiles
this stands for simplified molecular
input line entry system it's a it's
nothing new it's been around and in CHEM
informatics for quite a long time but we
can utilize it and sort of harness this
for feature ization of our compounds and
so it's a it's effectively a symbolic
string that's obtained from a
depth-first search through the compound
and then for any branching we have waste
her2 to describe that and so it creates
what's a string like what you see at the
bottom so there there are multiple ways
to make these compounds and
standardization can be a challenge this
will become important and then finally
chemical rules must be obeyed for
validity so there are ways to create if
you just randomly through these
characters together you would violate
the laws of chemistry so that there are
some challenges with generating valid
molecules in the types of using the
types of models I'm going to describe to
you so sort of bear those two things in
mind so what we use I eluded to this by
saying that what we do is look
the previous characters we use recurrent
neural networks so recurrent neural
networks take an input like you can see
with the X on the top and they make a
prediction or spit out an output like
you see them with the Y on the bottom
but recurrent networks have a hidden
state they have memory so they know what
they have previously generated as output
and they have weights which help them
remember how far back to look so this is
how these networks that we're going to
use will will remember the characters
they've previously generated and we
specifically use what's called what is
called an LS TM it stands for long
short-term memory it is a type of
recurrent neural network and we create
what is called an embedding it's a
numerical representation of the smile
strings when we train our model and then
we we put it through this LS TM and it
learns it learns to predict the next
character so if you follow along at the
bottom you can see it's predicting a 1
and then a couple of C's and then a 1
and the determination so the termination
is how we know that's that's its own
character that's when we know when it's
done with the compound that C 1 1 or C 1
C c c1 Terminator is effectively a
compound called benzene which hopefully
is not what's coming out of our model
because it's a carcinogen but it's easy
to draw so I've shown you our database
of compounds and how we feature eyes
them with smiles we do a little bit of a
selection off of off of the public
database and then we train this LS TM
model that I just showed you about and
we get new compounds great so how do
they look are they are they giving us
anything useful so yes they it turns out
to be a pretty good general model of
chemical space so this is a TC embedding
of a variety of compound properties and
the training data is shown in blue and
then we sample from our model and that's
shown in green and so you can see we can
recreate all of compound space pretty
well here and I told you a challenge
with these models is that whether or not
they can generate valid compounds and
these are actually a 95% of these are
actually balanced so it has learned some
rules of chemistry it's not just
out letters at us and we're able to also
generate a variety of a high degree of
novelty with our compounds so it's not
just spitting out the same valid
compound at once so that's great but one
of the challenges is with drug discovery
program we don't need a really general
model of the universe what we need is a
like a model that's really specialized
and we don't have a lot of data to train
that model when we start a drug
discovery program so we use this general
model as our basis and then we're going
to refine it for whichever region of
local space we want to look at so for
this purpose we use reinforcement
learning and this is actually a very
simple type of reinforcement learning
and we combine that with user feedback
so we take our pre chained LS TM model
we sample compounds from it and we score
it again this is our multi parameter
objective so we have a way of combining
models for the properties that we care
about and we score it and then we
retrain and we repeat that iteratively
so this is a very simple reinforcement
learning method called hill climbing and
we just do that several times and we
allow our users our chemists to give us
feedback if we need to adjust our
objective if there's something going
wrong it is a process that is still has
scientists very much in the loop so so
here's an example of what that might
look like we sample compounds from our
model shown in blue and then we're going
to score them we take the best it's
usually around 8,000 so you can see the
bottom ones seem to score the best and
we're going to retrain we present them
to our chemists and they can help us
refine what we're what the model is
doing so I will show you that with a
very quick video so you can see we are
selecting a compound so this is what it
actually looks like and it's going to be
represented as a smile string and then
we don't want it to look like that
compound the fioor and the small ring
that you saw so we're gonna say invert
it that's what those are all parts of
our multi parameter objective and then
we can add some other properties that we
care about like we don't want to deviate
too far from the starting compound so
we'll add that as a property as well and
we can the
how we represent it sometimes these are
smiles there are other ways of
representing compounds so sometimes we
adjust that based on what we want to get
out of it and then you can see that we
get a variety of compounds back and so
our chemists can give us feedback so
again you know I don't think we're ever
it'll be a long time before we're at the
stage where we completely have
scientists removed from the loop but but
this greatly helps us accelerate the
process so so does it really work
so yes so this is two representative
compounds for a program in ALS so ALS is
a mullah terrific lateral sclerosis also
known as Lou Gehrig's disease to many of
you it is a neurodegenerative disorder
and so we were able to take these
compounds and optimize their properties
to make drugs in a very short amount of
time so less than three months versus
the industry average of about a year and
a half and so the properties that we
optimized affinity so how tightly does
it bind is it soluble and then the last
one is called its ability to enter the
brain so this is a neurodegenerative
disorder so the compound has an
additional challenge it has to get back
get past what's called you a blood-brain
barrier which is a protective mechanism
so that's actually makes things even
more difficult so there's been external
demonstrations just recently as well so
there's a validation of compounds that
have been optimized into drugs by
machine learning and they found five
highly active drugs that have been
produced and so lastly sort of just to
conclude measuring models and
benchmarking our models is extremely
important to us and it's it's fairly
challenging in this case with generative
models do they give you something good
it's fairly easy to get a qualitative
read sometimes if the model isn't doing
so well you get a very explicit
qualitative read from your chemists in
the in in certain words that they're not
happy with but but how do you how do you
really measure this and so we've come up
with a way that we believe is a fair and
sort of balanced way of measuring these
generative models and we look at two
bacteria so can the model reproduce a
broad distribution of of chemical space
so what you saw with that teasing
embedding so how well can you reproduce
whatever chemical universe you given so
there's a variety of metrics that we've
posed in what we've developed as a
benchmarking suite the second one though
is that the general models are usually
really good at being general models but
they're not great once you start
optimizing them for a very specific
question
so does that model then also adapt or
are you able to get it to to to drive a
specific multi parameter optimization
and so how well then do you really focus
in on a specific area of space that
you're interested in and so we call this
benchmarking suite guacomole and we've
published recently a paper on it and
there is code up on get lab or github
excuse me
so with that end with that I would like
to thank you so these are some of the
people who've helped out with this work
as well so I'm available today and
tomorrow if you want to talk
you